so alright here's my story and it's kind
of a head-scratcher which is why I
brought it up with San Diego woman says
she now takes off her diamond engagement
ring before she goes to bed that's
because last week she swallowed it
during a game she says yes Jenna Evans
was having one of the you know those
dreams that you feel like are too real
they well that's what she says she was
having and in the dream she was she says
we she and her fiance we're in a very
sketchy situation involving a high-speed
train and bad guys and her Bobby her
fiance told her to swallow my ring to
protect it and she did so she woke up
and then she felt something she felt
something funny in her stomach and she
realized she'd actually swallowed the
ring yeah but I'm looking at this and
going how do you swallow a ring in your
sleep and stay asleep and stay asleep
how does this happen I don't think it's
gonna help if she takes it off and puts
it in a drawer because that'll just
become part of the dream how do you in a
dream open your mouth take the ring off
your finger and that's an emotional
thing that she's not really that happy
to be married your words burry your
whims anyway they ended up they ended up
doing an upper endoscopy a procedure
where a doc doctor puts a flexible tube
the cameras other thing and they were
able to get it out before it got in okay